Hello everybody, and welcome to another puzzle solving video. About a year ago, I did a series
of videos in which I solved a series of exercises on Chess.com's Tactics server, and I divided
these videos into different levels of puzzles. I did a beginner exercise video, I did a video
in which I solved intermediate level exercises, and then my most viewed video was the one in which
I solved the most complex Grandmaster level puzzles on Chess.com. And the way I defined
that were puzzles within the rating range, I believe that video was 2750 to 3100, which are
some of the most complicated and convoluted exercises that you will find on Chess.com.
And over the last couple of weeks, I've gotten a lot of requests on my stream to do another one
of these videos in which we do four or five of these exercises, and I walk you through kind of
in a live look at exactly how I approach these complicated exercises, what goes through my mind,
what variations I calculate, and essentially to give you an expose of how a GM tends to approach
master level tactics. And so I've listened, these videos are super fun to make. And so without
further ado, we're going to do four or five of these exercises, I'm going to target about a 35
or 40 minute video length. So hard to say exactly how many exercises we will solve, but as many as
we can in that time. And just like in the previous video, if we come across a particularly complicated
exercise, I can reproduce the position on chess space, which will allow me to make moves on the
board that is not for my benefit. But if I can sense that there are five or six move variations
that might be difficult for you to follow, then I will reproduce the position on chess space.
But otherwise, I will be using arrows a lot. And I will be speaking in variations,
especially if you're newer to chess, you can definitely have a chess board next to you and
on which you set up these positions and then make the moves as I'm saying them. But a great way to
practice your calculation would be to really push yourself to visualize these lines along with me,
even if you struggle to do that, that can really help you expand your ability to visualize long
lines, which of course is one of the most if not the most important skill when it comes to solving
tactical exercises and finding these tactics during the game. So I've upped the ante even
further in this in this video, the rating range now is 2800 to 3200. So it's entirely possible
that I will make a mistake on one of these exercises. And if I do, which is totally normal,
I don't have 100% accuracy. The point is not to avoid mistakes, it's to understand exactly why
you made them try to use every mistake as a way to advance your understanding of pattern recognition
and diagnose exactly what went wrong in the process of solving. So without further ado,
here we go. In the first position, it is white to move. And the first thing that I always do,
no matter what level of difficulty I'm solving is count the material because that gives you
a general sense of what it is that you're looking for. So here it seems that material is equal,
sort of no black is up two pawns. No, black is actually up three pawns, my goodness. So 367.
And white only has four pawns. White is a queen and knight, black is a queen and bishop.
Now the second thing that I see is that black's bishop is simply hanging. So king takes g1
is going to be a candidate move that we should return to. The second big thing that I'm noticing
is that black's king is caught in the crossfire of white's knight and queen and the knight and queen
is considered to be the strongest tandem in chess. You've probably come across a bunch of
mating patterns that involve the queen and knight. So my guess is that the solution is either going
to involve taking black's bishop and then dodging the checks that black's queen is inevitably going
to deliver, or there is some sort of mating construction with the queen and knight. So
let's start by understanding what happens after king takes bishop. So if we take the bishop,
black is probably going to give that check on e1. And I'm already pretty pessimistic about the king's
ability to escape the checks. King g2, I see that the queen can drop back to e4. And if we run to
the h file, king h2, there's this nasty check on h7. And if we drop back to g1, the queen is able
to keep pursuing the king from b1. So there's b1, e4, and h7, depending on where white's king runs.
It feels to me, king takes g1 results in a perpetual. So let's set that aside and let's
look at the direct approaches toward trying to checkmate black's king. So what kinds of moves
come to mind? Well, queen f7 check, to me, is the most obvious of the attacking attempts. That
forces the king to step back onto the 8th rank. There's king d8 and king c8. What I'm also
noticing is that black is not actually threatening any checks. That's super valuable. That's an
important piece of information that helps us tremendously, which tells me that we can make
potentially a quiet move in order to set up, let's say, a mating net. So we're getting somewhere.
Queen f7 check, after king to c8, I think just such a quiet move forces black to give up their
queen. We can slide our queen over to e7 with the obvious idea of preparing knight d6 check,
king b8, and then queen takes b7, or even queen d8 is going to be checkmate as a result.
So queen f7 check, king c8, queen e7. That's a pretty common mating pattern. So looking around
the board to see if black has any ways to stop that, I don't see it. Knight d6 is coming whether
black likes it or not. And if king b8, then we can immediately deliver the checkmate on d8. So
black is going to have to give up his queen. So after queen f7 check, it seems like king d8 is
the only other defensive approach. And here we can try to set up a similar mating construction.
We can actually capture the pawn on g7 with the very symmetrical idea of knight takes e6 check,
king c8, and then queen e8 mate. And the reason I see this kind of stuff quickly is just because
I'm very familiar with a lot of the mating patterns that arise when you have a queen and knight.
I've just done a lot of tactics on that topic. So queen f7 check, king d8, knight takes g7.
Does black have a way to stop knight takes e6 check? Man, my arrow drawing game is not
particularly advanced. So the one move that I see there after queen f7, king d8, knight takes g7 is
actually b6 with the idea of opening up a Luft square for the king on b7. But calculating that
line shows us that white can win the queen. Queen f7, king d8, knight takes pawn, b6. We take on e6.
The king slides over to c8. We deliver the check on e8, which would be mate. Now the king has b7,
but our knight is on e6. The black king is on b7, and our queens are making contact with each other,
which tells me look for a discovered check. And just such a discovered check exists. Knight d8
check picks up the black queen on e5, which is undefended. And that I think is the solution.
The key is to avoid taking the bishop and go directly for black's king. Let's test this out.
Check, knight takes g7. And I like to carry out the solution quickly as an added layer of
challenge. If you're solving exercises, you can absolutely pause on every move and double check.
But I hold myself to the highest standard, which means if I didn't solve the puzzle from the first
move, then, you know, for a grandmaster, that is essentially tantamount to getting it wrong.
Knight takes c6 check, and okay, black gives up the queen. But once again, the important line
is b6 here. Knight takes c6 check, king c8. We check on e8, and then we deliver another check on
d8. And it's also important to remember that you're not only searching for checkmate in these
types of positions. You're also searching for ways to exploit the weakness of your opponent's king
in order to pick up a bunch of material. So I was simultaneously looking for mating construction,
but I was also looking for things like discovered checks and forks. All right, on to the next one.
Whoa. Okay, so this is a crazy position. White has just captured our queen.
Now, just looking at the state of white's king tells me that this is some sort of forced mate.
These puzzles are typically a lot easier. I think I've already gotten it. So first of all,
the rook is hanging. The first move seems really obvious. It looks like it has to be knight e3
check. Forcing king e2, and now it appears that the bishop is going to have to step away somewhere
in order to set up a mating net. And I just think brute force in these types of cases
is incredibly effective. Note that knight d4 check is ineffective because that square is defended
by white's knight. So after knight e3, king e2, bishop g1 is a tempting move because it keeps
the knight on e3 protected, but then the king drops back to e1. You can take the pawn on c2
with check, but there it looks like we're moving in the wrong direction because the white king
could potentially even escape to b1. And taking the rook on a1 is totally ineffective. Again,
white is up a queen, so there's no amount of material that we could possibly win here
that is going to justify that. Also, our king is essentially checkmated. White threatens
queen f5 mate. So where else can we go after knight e3, king e2? Well, we can drop back to g3.
That keeps the e1 square protected, and after king takes e3, the bishop slides back to f4
with checkmate. So this is just all about being familiar with typical mating nets and having a
keen sense of mating patterns and also using process of elimination. So check, check, and mate.
This is just a mate in three, a simple exercise, and we move on to the next one. Okay, so here we
have opposite colored bishops. We have a middle game with what seems to be equal material. Yes,
seven pawns apiece. And you know, the first thing that jumps out at me, and I'm pretty sure this is
also what you're probably seeing, is that these two pieces can be forked by the move d4. Now,
I'm helped by the fact that I've set the rating range in such a way that I know that's not the
end of the puzzle. And after d4, the next thing that occurs to me is that white can play rook a
to d1. That's a very typical way of indirectly defending against a pawn capture, right? You're
just pinning the pawn to the queen. So rook a d1 actually threatens to eliminate the pawn of the
bishop. After d4, rook a d1, testing out the queen sacrifices really quickly, d e d c. No,
that doesn't seem effective. Maybe we have compensation, but we're definitely not winning.
What about d4 rook a d1 knight takes e3? That also seems ineffective. We're probably going to
lose the d4 pawn as a result. Now, another move that is circulating around my mind is the move
h5. This is a move that I saw pretty quickly. It dislodges the queen from g4, and I'm not sure
exactly how it's going to help us, but it's worth keeping this move in mind and testing it out
in various positions. We can play it immediately and then follow up with d4 on the next move, or
we can interpose the move order. We can play d4 first, rook a d1, and then play h5. So that seems
a little bit more forcing. Let's test out that move order first. So d4, rook a d1, and then h5.
So where can the queen go? It can drop back to e2. It can move over to f4. We have to basically
test every square. There's no easier way to do that. So after d4, rook a d1, h5, queen f4,
I think the move g5 is really strong because the queen is out of squares, which means it has to
take the pawn on g5, but then we're able to unpin our queen by trading queens and taking on c3.
And in the resulting position, our rook on a8 is actually doing a very important job of defending
the d8 square. Otherwise, that would have been made in one. So that's a promising start. d4,
rook a d1, h5. So we've refuted queen f4. What about queen back to e2? Well, the good thing
about that move is that the pawn on d4 now has one less attacker on it. So maybe we could sort
of move our queen in such a way that unpins it and simultaneously keeps the d4 pawn protected.
And I see actually two squares that fulfill that aim. Queen to h4 is one possibility,
and queen to b6 is the other. Now, there's no such thing as two possible solutions in
a chess.com exercise, so there's some sort of catch. But queen b6 looks totally winning to me.
White can play a5 there, attacking the queen, but the queen has a nice parking spot on b4.
And it seems to me that white is inevitably going to lose a minor piece. I don't see any
tactical shenanigans there. So that's good as well. d4, rook a d1, h5. Now, there is the h3
square, and that essentially leads to the same result, where white takes his eyes off of the
d4 pawn, allowing us to shift our queen over, let's say, to b6, keeping the d4 pawn protected
and reinforcing the threat, in that case, only of d takes e3. But if the bishop moves, then we can,
of course, take the knight, because the bishop will lose its pin on the queen. So again, we have
to check the move a5, right? So d4, rook a d1, h5, queen h3, queen b6. White tries a5. If we take
that pawn, then we lose our control over the d4 pawn. But once again, I don't see anything wrong
with queen b4. I suppose the white is knight a2 in that position, but queen takes a5, or queen a4
hits the knight, hits the bishop at the same time. But wait a second. After d4, white could bring the
other rook to d1. We have to test that as well, because what I'm noticing is that after d4, rook
fd1, h5, queen h3, queen b6, a5, if we play queen b4, then white will drop the knight back to a2,
and that knight will actually be protected by the rook. So we need to be a little bit more careful
in that case of where we put our queen. Fortunately, I think we have the c5 square.
So after a5 in that position, we could slide our queen up to c5. We're still hitting the bishop.
Knight a4, we can simply take on a4, and then take the bishop. I think that works out. Last thing we
need to check is why we can't start with h5. And I think the reason is pretty simple. h5 allows the
queen to slide over to the other side of the board, queen b4. And there, if we play d4, we haven't
gained anything. After rook a d1, the queen on b4 is actually better placed than it is on g4. So
that is why I think it is... Oh, we got it wrong. Okay, a mistake. So it probably is h5. It is
indeed h5. And see, this is where a lot of people assume that grandmasters never get puzzles wrong,
or my thinking process is flawless. Not at all. I would say that my accuracy rate for this rating
range is maybe about 75%, which means I get one puzzle wrong usually out of every five at least.
But that is really where the learning happens. Because if you got all of them right,
then what would really be the point of solving? Why would you need to solve if you already saw
everything to begin with? So obviously, here the move is d4. Rook takes d8 and dc. Everything is
simple. But let us understand why starting with d4 is wrong. Hopefully, you can see the screen
here. I switched windows. Yes, d4. Oh, it is bishop g5. That is obvious. And so the problem
was that I did not come back to the initial position and ask myself what the other candidate
moves were. I was fixated on refuting rook a d1, which to my credit, I did. h5 is winning. I
assessed this accurately. Queen h3, queen b6 is winning for black. But I forgot to come back to
the drawing board and make sure that I did not miss any other initial candidate moves. Long
variation, wrong variation. That is the famous phrase. And it is true so often when you are
solving tactics, right? If you are making a mistake, it is usually not on move 5 or 6 of
the line. It is actually on move 1. So bishop g5 here is super nasty. And if queen b4, then we
still play d4. What about rook a d1? Oh, we can play knight takes c3, f takes c3. And this is what
I missed. Queen to g5, hitting the pawn on g2 and threatening checkmate. And white cannot protect
the knight and protect against checkmate at the same time. Obviously, knight e4, we just play
bishop takes c4. So the knight cannot intercept the bishop's contact with g2. That is actually
what I missed. This idea of knight takes c3 and queen g5 using the other side of the board
and posing another threat. Very instructive. So do not forget to look at other candidate moves,
especially when we have spent a long time trying to refute a particular defense. Okay.
Okay. On we go to the other exercise. So far, we have done three. This is our fourth. It is
black to play. And to me, just looking at this position for a couple of moments, it seems obvious
that there is going to be some sort of mating pattern here. Maybe there is going to be some
way to win white's queen or promote the c-pawn. But that seems pretty doubtful to me, given that
white is up a rook and given that the rook is defending the queen. So in these types of exercises,
there is no magical way to approach it. You have to plunge in and get your hands dirty and start
calculating. And through the process of calculation, you start understanding things about
the way, you know, the mating mechanism. Sometimes you get lucky and the first move you consider is
the mating move. Sometimes you have to look at it a little bit longer. So the first move that I see
is queen e3 check. The reason I start with this move is because it is the most forcing. It forces
the king to step away to f5. Then I am noticing that the queen can drop back to g5 with check,
driving the king back toward e4. And I think it is checkmate. Bishop d5 check, king d3,
and queen d2 is mate. And the reason I saw that quickly is because I noticed that the c3 pawn
was anchoring the d2 square. So in my mind, I quickly came up with the idea of driving the king
back toward d3 and mating it on d2. And that is always a good thing to do when you are trying to
get a roadmap in these types of positions, is understand what squares your pawns are anchoring.
So the h pawn is anchoring the g5 square, and the c pawn is anchoring the d2 square. Both of
these squares are in fact used by the black queen as it hunts down white's king. Check, check, check,
and mate. That was a pretty elementary one. Let's move on and we'll, I think, manage to do about
seven or eight exercises. We're moving at a good pace so far, even though I've already made one
mistake. Let's try to keep it at that. Okay, white to play. So we're down two minor pieces currently,
but we can recapture one of them. Obviously, knight takes h4 doesn't seem to be the move that
gives black a tempo that he can use to keep the g file closed. So it seems obvious to me that gf is
the move that we should start with because it's forcing, it forces king takes f7. And there, I
think we should be careful not to allow the king to escape toward the center. So I'm pretty quickly
ruling out the check on g6 because it allows king e7, and it appears that we've reached a dead end.
So gf, king takes f7, queen h7 check seems a lot more feasible to me, especially because
king f6 obviously gets mated with rook g6. I don't even have to calculate further. I'm using
my intuition to determine that that is going to be made. I mean, the king has to go up to f5,
and there's three pieces surrounding it. We don't have to waste time calculating a line that we know
is going to result in checkmate. So after gf, king f7, queen h7, there is of course the move knight
e8 to g7, opening up an escape square on e8. Those types of moves are really annoying,
especially when, you know, black in this case is up two minor pieces, so they can afford to
give away some of them to keep the king safe. So gf, king f7, queen h7 check, knight g7. I'm
going to pause there for just a second and consider the various candidate moves.
Okay, so I'm looking at rook takes g7 check, king e8, queen takes h5 check, trying to take
all of black's pieces with check, king d8, queen takes bishop check. Already in that position,
we're up two pawns, and after king c7, we could tie up the knight with knight e5. Let's do that
again. Gf, king f7, queen h7, knight g7, rook takes g7, king e8, queen takes pawn check, king d8,
queen takes bishop check. I suppose in that position, black could block with the knight,
knight d7 to f6, and maybe that's a little bit overly complicated because black will also be
threatening a nasty check on c2. So we will be up two pawns there, but I'm not 100% convinced
that that is the most convincing solution. So let's look for a second to make sure that we're
not missing any more obvious mating construction. So gf, king f7 seems forced. Queen h7 seems
forced. Knight e5 doesn't seem to do anything. So queen h7, knight e8, g7. Now we could, I suppose,
take with the queen on g7, but that doesn't seem to make any sense. What about knight e5 check
in that position? Ooh, that could be promising. Knight e5 check, knight takes e5, rook takes g7,
king e8, queen takes h5, but the knight from e5 could then block the check on f7, right? So that
almost leads to mate, but not quite. Takes, takes, queen h7, knight g7. Okay, so what else can we
come up with there? Well, we can play rook takes g7 check, king e8, and the move that I'm just
about to settle on is queen takes h5 check. That's what we started with. I think in the resulting
position, it's safe to say that white is completely winning. So I'm going to cheat a little bit and do
what I said I won't do. We're going to play gf just because by process of elimination, we know
for a fact that this is the move. And we essentially know that queen h7 is the move. Let's take a
moment here. Knight e5 check, knight takes e5, then queen h7. That doesn't seem to change anything.
Yeah, it's got to be queen h7. Here we should pause for a second. So once again, knight e5,
knight takes e5 is what I was calculating for a bit. Rook takes g7, king e8. But the problem there
is if we take on h5, it's a cool idea because if black goes king d8, then we pick up the bishop
and deliver mate on e7. But unfortunately, the knight from e5 could block the diagonal check
with knight f7. So queen g6 check, king e7 also makes no sense. I think we've exhausted
all of the option. It has to be rook takes g7. Okay, now here we should pause for another moment.
Knight e5, once again, knight takes e5. We've already calculated that. Rook e7, not possible
because the bishop's guarding it. Now maybe we can take the bishop with the knight, but that seems
very unlikely because it's incredibly messy. Black starts checking us with queen c4, and the king is
unable to escape to f3 because the rook controls. So it's got to be queen h5. Good. And I would
imagine that it has to be queen takes h4. Yes, it is. So that is, in fact, the solution. And I saw
this line pretty quickly. It was the first line that I saw. But if you're kind of frustrated and
saying, well, why did I spend all this time looking at alternatives? That is where a lot of
the learning occurs, right? And sometimes you actually do get an unexpected tactic that results
in checkmate. I knew that this was probably winning, so I knew that this line was in our
pocket. If I didn't find anything else, I would simply go for this. But searching for other
continuations for out-of-the-box moves is where a lot of the pattern recognition is actually
developed. And I'm curious what the computer revalue here is in the final position because
after knight f6, okay, it's just plus 7. And it's plus 7 because black does have a check on c2,
but it can actually be blocked with knight d2. So the best move is queen f4 aiming for d6.
That's a really good move. If queen c4 check, oh, king d1. Now, this is complicated. King d1,
look at this move. And whichever way black checks, the white knight is able to block.
The knight is one of the most underrated defenders because it's able to control important squares
from the first rank or the second rank. That's what it does here. Queen d3, knight d2,
no more checks, and black is mated. And same with queen f1, knight e1. It's a very instructive
way in which white dodges all of black checks. Here, of course, b3 is straightforward. Nice.
Okay, on we go to the next one. Okay, and looking at this for just a couple moments,
black is down in exchange for a pawn. But more importantly, white's king seems to be in the
crosshairs of our queen and potentially of both our bishops. So taking a moment here to
understand with what sense of urgency we're operating, does white actually have a threat?
Queen g8 is not a threat because after king h6, the bishop on g7 does a great job of controlling
important squares. Queen h4 check is similarly not really a threat because of bishop h6.
So as we had stated in the first exercise, it's not that we will only look for quiet moves,
but a quiet move might be in the cards because we have the luxury of being able to afford one,
unless that quiet move comes with the bishop on g7, which would disrupt our ability to
potentially prevent all of these checks. So what comes to mind as possible candidate moves? Well,
I see two checks on the first rank. There's queen b1 and queen c1. And the hard part might be
for us to distinguish between them. That is a type of exercise that you see often at higher
levels on chess.com, where you get two similar checks and you have to spot some sort of minor
difference that often reveals itself only in some, you know, on move four or move five of
some variation. So again, there's no magical process. You just got to take one of these moves,
calculate it. And if it doesn't work, you've got to see how the other check perhaps helps you
improve on that line. You can also keep in mind both placements at once. This is a more advanced
form of calculation where you're essentially in your mind, the queen is kind of toggling between
c1 and b1. That might be a more efficient way of approaching the calculation without having
to manually calculate both of these lines. So let's take queen b1 check. I don't know why.
It just appeals to my intuition a little bit more. So why does two moves? There's bishop d1
and there's king e2. So bishop d1 is I think the more annoying move because it keeps the king safe.
So after bishop d1, bishop b3 comes to mind. So queen h4 check, bishop h6. Now it's important
to point out that rook h8 check in that position, king takes h8, queen takes h6, king g8, and we're
able to escape the check. So that's not a problem. So after queen b1, bishop d1, bishop b3,
queen h4 check, bishop h6, it seems like white has to play queen to g4 in order to protect not
the king but of course the bishop on d1. But this is where comparison really comes in handy. If our
queen was on c1 in that position, then with the bishop now on h6, I think we would be able to take
the pawn on d2 with check and then eliminate the bishop with a decisive material advantage
on the next move. So let's now transition to queen c1 check. Bishop d1, bishop b3, so still
no check on g8, that's ineffective. Queen h4 check, bishop h6, still no rook h8 check, and after
queen g4, we take on d2, and that I think might be the difference. Now we still need to calculate
queen c1, king e2, because that's not guaranteed checkmate. Can we find an efficient mating net
in that position? I think we can. Queen c1, king e2, we have bishop c4 check, just going down
the obvious line. King e3, queen e1 check. Okay, the king has to move up to f4. In a classical game,
I would probably stop calculating there, but in the context of a tactic, you often want to try
to push yourself to calculate a little bit deeper than you would in a real OTB game or a blitz game.
Queen takes f2, check in that position is surefire checkmate. King takes e4, I think we can mate with
the pawn, f5 checkmate, and if the king moves up to g5, then I think bishop h6 there is a very pretty
mate in one. So we can safely go with queen c1 check, that is correct. Bishop b3, bishop h6,
okay, they're going for rook h8, and our king nicely escapes the checks on g8. So this is called
the method of comparison, where you have two similar looking candidate moves, and you can
calculate them one at a time, but the more advanced method is essentially like Schrodinger's box,
right? You keep the queen on both of these squares at the same time, and you go down the line, and at
some point, the difference between those moves, it might become very obvious as it did in this
exercise. So we're on 30 minutes here, let's see if we can knock out two more exercises, and
hopefully we get something juicy. We've gotten some pretty good ones thus far, nothing, you know,
we haven't gotten any studies yet, so nothing crazy in terms of beauty, but definitely a couple of
very instructive exercises and a mistake that I've learned from. So it's been a successful session
thus far. Okay, so white is down two minor pieces, right? Black has three minor pieces,
black is up two knights, to put it more succinctly, and clearly this is going to be an exercise in
which we somehow have to get to black's king, and there is a bunch of checks that I'm already
seeing off the top of my head. There's bishop g5 check, there's even bishop to b6 check, which
we're going to rule out immediately, because after a takes b6, queen takes a, knight c6,
black has three minor pieces for the rook, and we're clearly at a dead end. So bishop b6 is
pretty, but pretty obviously ineffective. There's other check, there's queen h4 check, but the
problem with the checks on this diagonal is that black can block it pretty straightforwardly with
a pawn f6, or even knight e7, but f6 seems to be the big problem. So I don't think the correct move
would be a check on this diagonal. There is also queen a5 check, which seems like a more serious
option. So after queen a5 check, black can also block with a pawn, but there we can play the sort
of thematic bishop takes b6 check, and if a takes b6, we take with a queen. Now king e8 there gets
mated in two moves, so the king has to step forward to e7, but there it's also mated in two,
queen d6 check, king d8, and queen f8 is checkmate, and I'm, you know, already from the very
beginning, I noticed that the f8 square is undefended. That is a good idea in positions where
you're anticipating a possible checkmating combination, is to what I call think in terms of
squares. You, at the very start, even before calculating, take note of the possible squares on
which checkmate could conceivably be delivered, and you know, f8 is one of those squares. If the
knight had been moved away from g8, then the rook would have been guarding that square. So let's go
back to this line, queen a5 check, because b6 is not the only move. King e8 gets mated in two,
rook takes c8, and queen to d8. So after queen a5, we're down to king e7. Now at a minimum there,
I think we could probably just grab the bishop, and we're threatening a mate on d8. I mean, I find
it very hard to believe the black has anything resembling a defense there. It is important that
after queen a5, king e7, rook takes c8, black does have the move knight b8 to c6, but the queen has
another checkmating square on c5, or even queen a3 in that position is made in two. So that's also
pretty clear cut. Queen a5, b6, bishop takes b6 check. Black, of course, could refrain from taking
the bishop, but I don't think that's going to be effective. King e7, the simplest there might just
be queen c5 check, and then we grab the bishop with check, and queen d8 is made. So the mate there
is pretty prosaic. Man, without even calculating the other candidate moves, and there were a couple
more. There was rook takes bishop check. There was a move like queen b4 aiming for f8, but it's too
slow. It allows the knight to come out and block the access to the mating square. If you've already
calculated to checkmate, then you don't need to waste time looking at the other candidate moves.
If you're confident in your calculation, you can go ahead and make the move. Queen a5 check, bishop
takes b6, queen takes b6. Okay, they go king e8, rook takes c8, and after king e7, queen d8 is
checkmate. Okay, so for our final exercise, or maybe our final two exercises, I am going to set
the rating range even higher. I'm going to set it from 2,950 to 3,200, or let's say 3,000 to 3,200.
Let's see if we can get a really tough one. Of course, I've got to be careful what I wish for
because I really don't want to make a second mistake. So let's see what we get. And as we
get into this exercise, what you've, I'm sure, noticed, and you probably already noticed this
if you watched my first puzzle solving video, is that just because the rating of the puzzle is,
you know, 2,900 or 3,000, it doesn't mean that only a grandmaster can solve it. In fact, some
of those exercises, like we got a mate in three, right? And you might look at that and say, well,
that's a very basic exercise. Why is it rated 3,000? And, you know, the rating of the puzzle
is relative, right? It doesn't mean, oh, only a 3,000 can solve it. It just is a comparative
measure of how advanced the puzzle is compared to all of the other puzzles on chess.com. And some
made in threes can actually be really hard to spot in a real game, especially if there are other
tempting continuations. So take the designation of the grain of salt. And I hope that I haven't
lured you into like a clickbaity video where you were expecting, you know, insane exercises,
and you're getting made in threes. These have been pretty complicated. But my real point here
is that almost anybody can solve them, given enough dedication. You know, if you're a newer
player, you might have to set these up on a physical board and move the pieces around. But
most of the time, you can follow the logical steps and solve each of these exercises. Okay,
so enough talk. Let's knock this one out of the park. So I'm noticing that white is down in
exchange. I'm also noticing that queen takes g5, rook g8 loses the queen, so we can rule that move
out immediately. And there's obvious mating patterns related to the bishop on f6. So if we
could get our queen to h5, that would be immediate checkmate. So the moves queen g4 and queen f3 come
to mind. This might be another sort of comparison type exercise. Queen g4 to me seems more natural,
because in response to king g6, we would have queen takes g5 with mate on the next move. So
does black have a defense after queen g4? Well, again, brute force, right? At this point, just
brute forcing and looking at all of black's legal moves is a surprisingly effective method. So
looking at black's queen, does black's queen have a way to stop queen h5? No. Black's queen doesn't
have a single check. The rook on a8 has no moves. The rook on e8, rook h8, even that doesn't help.
Rook g8 only hastens the defeat. Queen h5 is then checkmate. I think queen g4 is just winning on the
spot. And perhaps the difficulty lies in refuting queen f3, because king g6 then prolongs the game.
Queen e4 check, by the way, is a tempting move, I think, for some people. But it actually helps
the king hide out on h6. And if you play queen g4 there, then black can already defend the g5 pawn
with rook g8. But queen e4 check actually makes no sense if you think in terms of squares. Because if
you do that, then you should spot the h5 square immediately as an entry point to black's king.
And once you spot that, queen g4, to me, is the most natural move. Okay, so this was 3082. That,
I admit, was a little bit anticlimactic. We should definitely do at least one more. And here we go.
Okay, so another chaotic position, a king hunt. What's the material count? We are down. We're down
a minor piece and some pawns. So we're down a minor piece. Our own king is in mortal danger.
Black is threatening a check on a3. Black is attacking our queen. So all of this is essentially
telling me that this is probably going to be some sort of series of checks that is going to lead to
checkmate or maybe gain of material. So what can we come up with here? And it's important not to
get overwhelmed in these types of positions. You approach them the same that you would approach
any other position with a wide open king. You generate the list of checks, and then you just
go through them one by one. And they're often easier to calculate than it appears. Having said
all that, I'm probably going to make a mistake. So what comes to mind here? Well, queen takes
knight check just leads to a trade of queens. We can rule that out. Knight takes f7 check.
Bishop takes f7. We can take black's queen, but then black is going to take our queen,
and I don't see anything in that position. We're just down two minor pieces. Okay, so knight f7,
bishop f7. I don't see any desperados. If we take the rook, then we lose our rook with check. That's
out of the question. So what other checks come to mind? Knight e4 check. I think black can just
snap that knight off the board. What about knight c4 check, knight dc4 check? Well, then if black
takes with the queen, then our other knight captures, and we win the queen with check. So
knight dc4 check, black can of course take that with the bishop. Okay, so in that position, both
queens are hanging. So we could perhaps try to, you know, maneuver our queen away with check,
with check, but we don't have an immediate check because the black king defends both c6 and c7.
And if we give a check on d1 with our rook in that position, the black could actually take the rook
with a queen, and once again, our queen is going to be lost. So knight dc4, bishop takes c4 might
also be a dead end. Okay, that means we need to go back to the drawing board. Are there any
candidate moves that we're missing? Maybe there's a quiet move, right? We shouldn't rule that out.
Well, first, I'm looking a little bit more carefully to see if there are any checks that I
may have missed. Let's look at knight dc4 for just another second, bishop takes c4. In that position,
are there any hidden checks? Rook f6 doesn't make sense. Rook d1 we looked at. I don't think so.
Okay, so we go back to the initial position. There's also knight e4 check, but we've been
there before. Just queen takes e4, I don't see what we gain. So that means it's time to think
in silence for a little while. Give me 30 seconds. I'm going to try to focus and figure out what I'm
missing here. This is the fun part. This is where you get to watch me suffer, because normally the
rolls are reversed in the speedrun games. Okay, I've spotted one move that I need to look at,
but I'm pretty pessimistic about it, which is knight e to c4 check, right? Both knights can
move into c4, but neither one of those moves seems to do all that much. The king can just drop back
to d7, but then there's knight b6 check. So wait a second, let's set that aside for a second. That's
one candidate move that I've come up with so far. I'm going to look at this for a little while
longer and see if I can come up with any others. Aha, I think I might have gotten it. And
I think this is the logical continuation, which is that if you've ruled out all the checks,
then you move on to the captures, right? And I think there is a capture that I saw this move
initially, and I ruled it out because white is down a minor piece to start the exercise. So you
wouldn't really think that you're able to win enough material to justify some sort of trade,
and yet I think that's exactly why this exercise is difficult. So knight e to c4 check
I think fails for a variety of reasons. The king can drop back to d7, and I don't see a follow-up
in that position. Now the capture that caught my eye suddenly was rook takes bishop, because it
does defend against black's threat, right? Queen a3 check there is no longer a possibility. But
the other thing it does is it opens up the secondary possibility of knight takes f7 check,
which would potentially, if the smoke clears, trap the rook in the corner. So after rook takes a2,
I actually think the line is pretty simple. If black takes the queen, then we first take on f7
with check. Remember the bishop is gone in that line. The king has to move. We recapture black's
queen. At that point material is equal, but the rook in the corner is trapped, and black is at
the very least going to be down an exchange and probably even a rook, because I don't see a way
for black in the resulting position to trap the knight in the corner. So after rook takes a2,
if black plays queen takes a2, then we can capture the knight with check, and we hunt the black king
down. King takes e5. Again, that's not really a line you even really need to calculate with the
king in the center like that, surrounded by three pieces. There is going to be a checkmate. I think
knight c4 check probably does the trick. Knight f3 check, both of those moves I'm pretty sure
will lead to forced mate. So after rook takes a2, queen takes a2, queen takes knight, king e7. Also
there's the obvious queen takes c7 check, and at the very least we can pick up the rook and be up
a minor piece, and we're mating the black king. So I think rook takes a2 is a hidden capture
that does the trick. Knight takes e5, we also need to check. Rook takes a2, knight takes e5,
because if we blindly take the queen, then black takes our queen, and black is up a minor piece.
But after rook takes a2, knight takes e5, at that point there's a host of other checks that we can
now give. In particular, I'm looking at knight e4 check. The idea is to force black's king onto e7
so that we can move our queen away with check, so that in turn we could take black's queen and not
have to lose our own. So rook takes a2, knight takes e5, knight e4 check. If king e6, then we
can maybe give a, I don't know, a follow-up check on c5. That looks pretty overwhelming too.
And that's a line that we can trust intuitively is going to be winning. Let's go for it. Rook
takes a2. Okay, rook takes b7, knight takes f7, and we pause here for a second just to make sure.
Order of operations, we take the queen first, we take the rook, and that was a 31-41 puzzle. That
was a difficult one because of the amount of candidate moves that we had to sort through.
But again, I think you're able to see that that was an eminently solvable exercise.
It's just that, well, the tempting move to me was definitely knight dc4 check because that's one of
those moves you look at it and, yeah, that's got to be the solution, you know. It's a desperado
sack and you're opening up an attack on the queen, but you have to think concretely, and if you
calculate concretely, then you're able in most cases to eliminate these tempting moves which
often stand in the way of the solution. Rook takes a2 is really a sexy move. It's not a check,
and your brain might be screaming that the move absolutely has to be a check. It never has to be
a check, and you always have to look at the other tactical moves, in particular, captures and
threats, right? That's the common wisdom checks, captures and threats, and it applies in super
advanced puzzles as well. Okay, we're up to 45 minutes, folks, so we're already over the length
of the video that I had intended. I think we managed to get through about 10 exercises. Some
of them were quite a bit easier than the ones that we got in the first iteration of the video,
but nonetheless, right, this is the realistic sample size of what you get at the higher levels
of chess.com's tactics server. I hope you enjoyed the video. We didn't have to set any puzzles up
on chess space. I hope you were able to follow the variations. I know that there was a lot of
calculation, and again, right, if you're newer to chess and you weren't able to follow some of
these lines, that's okay. Acquiring the ability to visualize long lines is a long process and a
laborious process that you have to keep at it. We made one mistake in which I got excited by the
progress that we made refuting a particular defense, and I forgot to go back to the initial
position and check to see if the opponent had any other possible defenses, and I missed a pretty
embarrassingly simple defensive resource with Bishop g5. Got the move order of two important
moves wrong. Very instructive mistake. And on that note, folks, we are going to end the video.
I will definitely be putting out more puzzle-solving videos in the next couple of weeks
because I know that they are well-received. Hope you enjoyed. Happy puzzle-solving,
and I will see you in the next video. Bye.